تحيه طيبه من الفضاء الخارجي الحمد لله
فضل الله وصلنا لهذه المرحله نحن الان
يعني نعيش حلم ما كنا نتخيل ان هو ممكن
يصير حقيقه الحمد لله
بدعم من الحكومه بدعم القيادتنا بدعم
اسرنا بدعم من الجميع هذه الرحله ما
تمثلني انا لوحدي ولا تمثل بس طموحي
بالعكس يتمثل كل الوطن العربي يتمثل كل
السعوديين الحمد لله ان احنا جاتنا هذه
الفرصه ان احنا فقط نقدر نوصل الان لمحطه
الفضاء الدوليه لكن بعد كده عندنا اكيد
طموحات اكبر واكبر من هالقمر منها المريخ
لازم نستكشف الفضاء هذه هي فرصتنا زي ما
تشوفوا دحين
جنسيات كثيره متجمعه في مكان واحد في
الفضاء هو اللي يجمع كل هذه الجنسيات
مختلفه بافكارهم
واستكشافاتهم معلوماتهم
وهذا رائد الفضاء السعوديه علي القرني قال
في اول كلمه له بعد دخول الى محطه الفضاء
الدوليه قال ان تجربه التي سيعيشها
تاريخيه
الحمد لله بتيسير وفضله وصلنا الى محطه
الفضاء الدوليه شكرا
لحكامنا
بقيادتهم
وحكمتهم ونظرتهم في المستقبل وتطور
البشريه شكرا لاهتمامهم بمجال الفضاء شكرا
لاسرتي على الدعم اللامحدود اللي حضيته
منهم شكرا لزوجتي واهلي جميعا شكرا لهيئه
السعوديه للفضاء
بتحقيق هذا الحلم للناس وقريبا ان شاء
الله سينظمون لنا الكثير باذن الله شكرا
لنا
على هذه الفرصه كانت تجربه تجربه الاقلاع
تجربه تاريخيه تجربه سوف تخلد في ذاكرتي
الى الابد
اذا بعد ان استهل رائدان الفضاء رحلتهما
الى محطه الفضاء الدوليه عبر عدد من
السعوديين عن مدى اعجابهم وفخرهم بهذه
المهمه نتابع
اليوم احنا قادرين الحمد لله نوصل الفضاء
بشهاب وشاب سعوديين مسلمين عرب قادرين
ينقلون رؤيتنا ويرفعون اسمنا في هل العالم
كله والله شيء عظيم جدا شعور بالفخر شعور
باعتزاز وطني يوصل للمكان هذه وباذن الله
منها لاشياء افضل وافضل هذه مجرد بدايه بس
بصفه امراه ومواطنه سعوديه اشعر بفخر
وسعاده بالغين اليوم انه حدث تاريخي وكلنا
متحمسون حقا لتوجه رائدى الفضاء لمحطه
الفضاء الدوليه لاول مره
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات